on va revenir sur cette affaire cette
deuxème affaire un sénateur accusé
d'avoir drogué une députée pour abuser
d'elle que s'est-il passé ça cette
histoire elle est incroyable j'y croyais
pas alors
c'est complètement fou c'est un un
député de 66 ans non un sénateur pardon
de 66 ans qui est sénateur d'ailleurs
pas un député non c'est un sénateur
sénateur centred droit Joël guerot il
est âgé de 66 ans il en est à son 3e
mandat il est en Loire Atlantique
et mardi dernier il avait invité une
députée là pour le coup Sandrine josau
qui a 45 ans qui est député du MoDem il
avait invité à dîner à son domicile et
début de la soirée c'était plutôt bien
passé
et le le sénateur lui offre une coupe de
champagne qu'elle accepte je précise
qu'ils se connaissent depuis 10 ans
qu'ils sont amis et qu'ils ont une
relation assez suivie mais pas une
relation enfin il se passe rien au
niveau sentimental entre ces deux-là là
je précise également que Joel guerillot
est marié père de cinq enfants d'accord
et donc il l'invite à dîner il lui offre
une coupe de champagne et un quart
d'heure 20 minutes après avoir bu cette
coupe de champagne euh cette jeune femme
Sandrine josau se sent pas bien elle a
elle se elle se met à transpirer elle a
des sueurs euh son cœur se met à battre
beaucoup plus vite une sorte de
taticardie euh et là elle comprend euh
qu'elle a été droguée et elle se
souvient même avoir vu
son ami enfin son ex-ami maintenant Joël
guerot sortir d'un tiroir de la cuisine
un petit sachet en plastique transparent
et avait un produit blanc à l'intérieur
donc elle l'a pas vu mettre dans le
verre mais en tout cas elle a fait le
rapprochement entre ce ce mouvement et
l'état dans lequel elle se trouve et là
elle a fait preuve d'un sang- frroid
incroyable il faut dire que le domicile
de de ce sénateur est assez proche de
l'Assemblée nationale elle part en très
mauvaise état é à l'Assemblée nationale
elle demande du secours à des collègues
qui étaient encore sur place qui compte
tenu de son état ont prévenu les secours
le SAMU est arrivée elle a étaé
hospitalisée on a fait des analyses de
sang d'urine et on s'aperçoit qu'elle
avait de l'extasie dans dans le corps ch
et à partir de là elle a évidemment
déposé plainte auprès des services de
police c'est le 3è district de police
Judici on a on a trouvé les analyses
elle était testé positive à plusieurs
drogues amphétamine opiac cannabis
cocaïne
méthadone c'est
lui c'est le c'est le sénateur qui est
ceux qui contestent lui Jo gu alors lui
lui frère cocaï et d'ailleurs je précise
que lorsqu'il a été interpellé le
surlendemain il y a une perquisition
évidemment fait à son domicile on a
retrouvé d'exasas ou alors défense il
s'est défendu sa défense est lunaire g
oui alors c'est absolument lunire alors
je précise juste Cyril que la députée
elle se méfia un petit peu parce qu'au
départ il l'invite pour fêter les
sénatoriales voilà et donc elle pense
que c'est au restaurant puis après il
dit non c'est chez moi elle pense qu'il
y a d'autres gens elle arrive elle est
toute seule donc elle se méfie et après
c'est pour ça que très vite elle se dit
il m'a fait ingérer quelque chose sa
défense lui c'est incroyable alors son
avocat dit oui ce jour-là il était pas
bien son chat est mort son chat qu'
l'adorait est mort il était pas bien un
de ses amis son meilleur ami lui annonce
qu'il est très malade donc il va pas
bien et puis il a une petite coupe de
champagne il se dit je vais prendre un
verre de champagne et on lui a donné un
produit dit son avocat on lui a donné un
produit un euphorisant il y a quelques
temps il met dans la coupe de champagne
c'est une coupe colorée il met dans la
coupe de champagne puis finalement il
boit pas la coupe il sort mais il laisse
le produit dans une coupe de champagne
et quand la députée arrive il sert le
champagne dans la coupe ne se souvenant
pas qu'il y a le produit à l'intérieur
c'est totalement délirant alors alors il
il dit il plaide de l'erreur de
manipulation oui parce qu'il dit j'ai
pas voulu lui faire ingérer ça je
pensais que c'était un œuf horizon que
j'ai mis dans la coupe et puis je l'ai
oublié il y a rien de conscient chez moi
voilà pour lui faire que le ver était
mal essuyé de la veille c'est pour ça
qu'il restait des produits sur le
ver ça paraî plus que léger ça para plus
que léger d'accord alors il y a Gérard
larch qui demande sa démission le
président du Sénat qu'est-ce qui va
passer il lui a demandé de se mettre en
RET M r M r va sere donc là il y a
la ok très bien donc làén son patron
ou pH ouais était venu le soutenir lors
des sénatoriales exactement on va passer
à cette trè histoire dramatique un jeune
de 16 ans tué lors d'une fête de village
euh c'est un truc de fou ça c'est Thomas
qui a été tué poignardé dans une bagarre
les fesses sont déroulées dans la nuit
de samedi à dimanche une expédition
punitive c'est dans un petit village de
la PR près de Valence dans la Drome à
crépool une grande un grand bal un grand
bal dans ce petit village de campagne
tous les tous les les jeunes et un peu
moins jeunes d'ailleurs d'ailleurs
viennent s'amuser il y avait longtemps
qu'ils avaient pas organisé un bal
l'ambiance était plutôt festive tout se
passait bien jusqu'à 2h 2h10 du matin au
moment où le bal touche à sa fin il y a
une une arrivée massive d'une dizaine de
de de personnes qui très vite ont voulu
rentrer à l'intérieur de la de la salle
de de bal refoulé par le videur parce
que d'une part parce que c'était fermé
d'autre part parce que c'était une
soirée privée euh une bagarre éclate
entre le vide et ces jeunes qui sont
arrivés ça a dégénéré parce que d'autres
se sont emmêlés pour défendre le videur
ils ont sorti des couteaux il y a une
bagarre générale il plantait un témoin
dit il plantait à
l'aveugle il tapait des coups de couteau
absolument partout le videur a eu les
doigts sectionnés coupés
sectionnés et malheureusement dans cette
histoire un jeune Thomas 16 ans a été
mortellement touché par des coup coup de
couteau alors c'est un déflement
déferlement déferlement de violence il y
a même un témoin qui dit c'était
tellement violent qu'au début j'ai cru
un attentat terroriste tellement c'était
violent elle a vu les les poignards
effectivement il y avait des très
longues lames j'ai j'ai vu qu'il y avait
une lame de 25 cm donc c'est des des des
vraiment des couteaux pour tuer quoi ils
sont venus pour tuer il y a deux blessés
graves et en tout il y a eu six autres
personnes blessées et 17 personnes
touchées et si le vigile avait pas été
là parce que il s'interpose ça aurait pu
être encore beaucoup plus sanglant comme
bilan c'estjà justement qu'est-ce qu'on
sait des agresseurs bah pour le moment
il y a pas énormément de choses on se
dit que peut-être ils ont été refoulés
une première fois qu'ils sont arrivés
suite on a parlé aussi d'un quartier
sensible quartier la monnaie de roman
suriser qui est distant de quelques
kilomètres voilà pour le moment est-ce
que c'est une expédition punitive
planifiée est-ce que c'est une vengeance
après avoir été refoulée de la soirée
voilà pour le moment à l'heure où on
parle là il semblerait qu'il se soit
présenté en tout début de soirée ils ont
été déjà vus à ce momentlà avec des
lames de 25 cm et c'est à ce moment-là
qu'on les a refoulé et comme il l'aurait
très très mal pris ils se sont dit on va
revenir en fin de soirée et on le fera à
l'extérieur et c'est là qu'ils ont
attaquer les jeunesdition une expédition
punitive parle d'une expédition punitive
exactement il y a Hugo un autre jeune
homme qui est à la soirée et
connaissance de Thomas qui a
malheureusement vu tout ce qui s'est
passé il a dit Hugo j'étais vers
l'entrée j'ai vu Thomas se faire planter
un couteau dans le cœur et dans la gorge
un hélico l'a amené mais il est passé
malheureusement je suis choqué c'était
un collègue à moi on était au collège
ensemble je l'ai vu mourir il y a eu une
bataille entre les les agresseurs et
ceux qui ont eu le courage de leur faire
face oui parce que les les autres à
l'intérieur av avaient pas de couteau
avait pas d'armes ils avaient juste
leurs bras et leur et leurs pieds pour
se défendre contre une horde sauvage
d'une bonne dizaine d'individus armé de
couteau qui était arrivé comme on vient
de le dire une première fois puis une
deuxième fois pour régler régler leur
compte alors il y a un il y a un Chalon
où vivait Thomas les habitants sont sous
le choc comme Aline j'ai failli me
fondrer ce matin je suis totalement
bouleversé c'est inexplicable je le
connaissais très bien ses parents sont
des gens formidables il n'y avait pas
plus gentil et poliis que Thomas
toujours à traverser la rue pour vous
dire bonjour souriant c'est un acte
gratuit il n'y a pas de mot et c'est
vrai que c'est un acte gratuit
absolument il avait 16 ans céit un rugby
man tout le monde l'adore ainsi que sa
famille devant le lycée ce matin c'était
l'état de choc absolu donc voilà c'est
on le voit derrière vous là c'est une
mort tragique pour une expédition
punitive c'est dramatique dramatique
mais ça veut dire quoi expédition
punitive en fait ça veut dire quo on
veut se ver on Vanger donc on va dans
une soirée on rentre pas dans la soirée
on revient avec frré et on se dit qu'on
revient avec des copains et voilà est ru
avec des copains par pas rentré dans la
soirée avec des couteaux ils ont voulu
se vengerêre rentré j'attends l'enquête
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe non mais
j'attends l'enquête on attend de savoir
parce que ça me paraît juste
complètement abant quoi c'estd c'est
même pas l'ensuvagement de la société là
c'est quand même c'est des barbares en
fait on rentre pas dans une soirée on
arrive avec des lames et on et on
poignard les gense
incroableors et c'est très bizarre oui
je précise que tout se passe c'est bien
c'était bon enfant à l'intérieur c'est
vraiment des des gens du du coin qui se
connaissent et qui s'amusaient euh sur
un bal après après le covid enfin il y
avait tout un tas de de d'événements qui
n'avaient pas permis de réorganiser de
bal depuis plusieurs années donc c'était
le premier mal depuis un petit moment et
tout le monde était content pour
l'instant l'enquête il interpeler
personne non non non au moment où ça le
drame s'est passé il n'interpelle
personne et là il tente de remonter
petit à petit de travailler sur les
différentes pistes mais c'est pas si
facile et c'est vrai qu'il y avait 350
jeunes dans la salle des fêtes donc il
sont entrés là ouais c'est ça et et et
ils sont revenus en voiture à deux
bandes et puis ils ont taper tout ce qu'
pouvait c'est un tout petit village de
530 habitants donc c'est sidérant en
milieu rural comme ça c'est incroyable
je pense que l'enquête sera
effectivement compliqué mais je pense
qu'ils y arriveront parce que d'abord
ils ont été vus par plein de par plein
de gens et pu c'est le petit la petite
ville roman sur iser roman sur iser
c'est pas non plus c'est pas Chicago
hein c'est sûr c'est sûr que c'est il
vont ils vont être retrouvés très très
vite on espère en tout cas on pense fort
à la famille de de ce jeune homme Michel
est avec nous il fa faire le point sur
les affaires et c'est vrai qu'il y a eu
des révélations incroyables ce weekend
notamment sur l'attentat d'aras on va on
va d'abord commencer par ça après on
viendra sur cette histoire de ce
sénateur qui a été placé en garde à vue
une histoire complètement folle il a été
il est accusé d'avoir drogué une député
cette histoire il fol Michel va nous la
raconter et enfin on évoquera ce drame
ce jeune de 16 ans qui a été tué par une
dizaine de personnes armé au couteau
dans un village dans la Drome c'était
hier d'abord alors vraiment les
incroyables révélations sur le tueur
d'aras euh il paraît que lors de son
interrogatoire le lendemainc son attaque
mortelle au couteau qui a coûté la vie à
Dominique Bernard il nargit les
policiers oui tout à fait il a eu
pendant ses 96 heures de garde à vue une
attitude de défiance en permanence ou en
quasi
permanence on le voit dire on l'entend
dire vous m'avez manqué non je rigole
euh il imaginait brisait ses menotes
comme dans les films il dit ça serait
stylé quand même compte tenu du crime
qu'il avait commis euh c'était quand
même assez mal venu ces 96 he de gardeà
vue ont été ponctué de je vous laisse
deviner des silence aussi où je ne
souhaite pas m'exprimer ou encore il se
mettait à faire une prière coranique
marmonnaé les yeux vers le ciel après il
explique qu'il voulait aller au paradis
donc parce que il essayait donc de faire
de bonnes
actions en étant un bon
musulman fidèle à sa religion qui est
l'Islam et il conclut en disant seul
Dieu décidera si mon acte en fait partie
alors ce qui est il y a un élément qui
est incroyable avant son passage à
l'acte et sur son passage à l'acte c'est
qu'il avait tout prévu tout écrit c'est
ça qui alors il avait absolument tout
préparé tout minuté dans son sac à dos
il y avait quatre feuillets qure
feuillet où tout son projet criminel
était marqué comme un scénario avec les
horaires les horaires de bus également
pour partir au cas où il aurait réussi à
partir il avait marqué aussi les les
heures des sonneries du lycée quand il y
a la récréation et quand les cours
reprennent il avait également projeter
d'acheter un téléphone portable il y a
même le tarif de ce téléphone 129 € euh
voilà en gros il avait tout préparé et
ce probablement depuis des semaines
peut-être même des mois il avait
préparer son geste criminel il il a même
envoyé la Une de Marianne décapité sur
un compte télégram oui alors il a envoyé
deux deux deux deux messages alors on n
pas les les destinataires ça sera a
priori des des des musulmans
Russ ils ont pas été identifiés pour
l'instant en tout envoyé quand même des
vidéos de de décapitation
pasimag de photos une qui représente
char Hebdo et l'autre qui
représente Marianne décapité
effectivement alors lors de son attaque
il blesse au thorax david v un prof de
PS qu'il prend en chasse dans la cour de
récréation et leur échange à ce
moment-là a été révélé je l'interp je
l'interpelle immédiatement lui disant
Mohamed mais qu'est-ce qui se passe
qu'est-ce que tu fais sans qu'il me
donne de réponse j'étais obsédé par son
regard noir et froid il a commencé à
parler en ces termes qui te donne l'air
que tu respires qui est le seul Dieu je
lui ai posé la question qu'est-ce que tu
veux Mohamed que je me convertisse je
luii parlé de mes enfants et cetera tout
à fait et il faut préciser que David
l'avait eu comme ce ce ce professeur
l'avait eu comme élève en 6e et en 4e
donc il le connaissait très bien et
quand il le voit arriver avec ses yeux
de fou il a un moment de sidération et
ensuite quand il comprend qu'il est venu
pour en découdre et et pour commettre
l'effet qu'il a commis il a essayé de de
d'intervenir il a été blessé c'est euh
il a pris trois coups de couteau un au
cou un au thorax et un dans le dos alors
euh vous allez voir he il y a les
révélations incroyable notamment dans Le
Parisien